yeah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the
gingerbread house building challenge
where we're gonna be building
gingerbread houses oh man my voice is
still not high percentage so you may be
guessing what that is and you're gonna
find out at the end of the video that's
coming oh [ __ ] oh ho ho
all right so anyway welcome to the
gingerbread house building challenge
we're gonna each take a turn to build a
gingerbread house in a certain amount of
time how much time we have five minutes
yeah five minutes out there okay we have
five minutes to build the best
gingerbread salad we can who were those
words are we have a magic we have
gingerbread pieces of house we have
icing we have gummy gummy leaves we have
holly berries we have a dummy lights for
house we have red chair it's for house
we have a candidate for house and we
have squeezed for squeeze are we going
to paper-rock-scissors for I say with
Queens gingerbread making time try some
peanut raid on milk and egg I cannot eat
this house but got them and I can build
house you can build house you know II
thought he goes star for Christmas but
he not to be sad he'd be happy I can be
happy because I be not dead you'll be
dead from starvation but not from
allergy allergy that is correct got me
alergy who his biggest squeeze oh wow
that is nice squeeze
but those nice effect that brewed ah the
semen covered reindeer okay we'll go
first
we broke Vince's now we big squeeze
whoever gets this squeeze fires alright
blindfold close your eyes I think you
have small squeeze I squeeze you have
nice squeeze you go first
okay can you go please why are we going
first second third we're building at the
same time at the same time it was feel
bad okay so we're not going yet we're
just assembling everything so if all of
you at home I know you're just tailing
with in anticipation of what we're gonna
craft here but don't let him go hold it
did I hit record take them by the [ __ ]
you've got dimer huh we can just no
we're gonna do it in three minutes I
think five is agree would you only three
to assemble and then three to decorate
no [ __ ] are we gonna do this I don't
[ __ ] know maybe that maybe three
minutes was a bit of a eager
anticipation challenge challenge my name
is challenge McGee and I'm here to
challenge you to all [ __ ] off Ethan why
minute 30 we're at the halfway point
we're doing great guys wait what we're
at the halfway point
but the halfway point Tyler you better
eat and be ready oh no no you guys suck
I am the best
look at me I'm really great my dick is
really big alright alright nothing babe
oh that's not the baddest [ __ ] I've
seen it's amazing the bad [ __ ] ride
into town on a Harley Davidson oh that
was weird a no my bag broke fromo throw
ball my
sack broke oh look he's too much comb no
it's too much and that's that's it
everybody ever hands off ok alright so
that's stage one
oh my my chimney no we spend time can I
fix mine let me give it to you a big
sack fix my house my last you know you
have to start stage two like that yeah
everybody everybody stop stop giving
this oh no that was Stage one
there was the funny stage
so since we hereby [ __ ] these houses
that we were going to use in the second
part of the video where we were then
gonna destroy them what the [ __ ] it was
gonna happen anyway it wasn't gonna
happen
we had cloths we're gonna put down for
the second party now I'll have to eat it
all and then die because I'm allergic to
these you need to be punished you need
to be punished
get the dodgeballs you [ __ ] up get up
against the wall all the way up all the
way up against the wall hands against
hands against the wrong legs
[Music]
do you regret coming out here do you
regret it say you don't love it here yes
all right you feel punished you're a bad
boy you're a naughty elf
in the spirit of Christmas it's now 2 V
1 so wait hold on hold on in the spirit
of Christmas of togetherness it's now us
versus you I mean I think that's
perfectly out of the the shambles of our
destroyed family home we have to build
again rebuild regions build that's what
Christmas is about and we are gonna
build a prettier house than you could
ever imagine to be honest what Christmas
is about it's about giving what you can
no Christmas is about being better than
you are decorated than you
he's gonna take the two of us to be
better than you that's right because
you're gonna take you're handsomer
you're smarter you're better you're
better at building houses senators
building houses
you're better at keeping your house from
being destroyed huh by a freak moot
accident I don't know what they're
better at breakdancing you're better at
having red hair
you're better at having a huge dick
you're better at having a small dick you
should be better at being afraid because
we're about to destroy your house yeah
we're gonna beat up your better dads
puss
yeah set the timer to three minutes no 5
this time 5 minutes we got 3 minutes
ready 5 minutes 5 minutes 3 minutes we
got three minutes we're gonna assemble
this decorate it what are we going for
here we have a snazzy nope no that's the
markiplier who is absolutely the market
are ways to do it well and a wise is
leaking out the side you know like holy
Zach before are you know what I'm gonna
create a pool to dip in it'll be easier
to dip the parts and stick them together
then it will be to squeeze them on this
will be the base this will be the front
door it's kind of assembled in some way
I got glue
blam good dog loves Oh we'll have the
back right there oh yeah okay that make
the connecting wall you got it you know
how didn't you plan the Sims and you
just start placing walls randomly in a
house because you're too tired to
actually think about it yeah that would
look better than this not one of those
stack okay now we have to strategically
place these yeah we got to use we're
gonna be the my sheer volume of weather
don't let it fall it's it's powered by
our love
and there's not a lot left of that
remember crank apply here our house will
be held together by tumblr gifts tumblr
gifts then we know what to do did you
make any progress I think we have a
clear way there's a distinct winner here
I think 100% we are fully aware and
fully erect the house the houses see
Tyler like we were talking about the
foundation of this house it's built on
love and it's built on trust
yeah love and trust what's uh what's
your foundation made out of looks like
some shitty cardboard no no explain tell
the time is up how the time's up you
can't continue decorating after the time
is done now that the time is done Tyler
on your SATs did you continue the test
taking once they said hey times up
pencils down Tyler when you were playing
water polar wouldn't win the when the
referee went hoot-hoot on his whistles
you can continue throwing that ball
around of course
Tyler when you as a sperm hit the egg
did you keep bearing until you went out
the other side no you stopped you
stopped you stopped you won that race
okay all right now we're done anyway
yeah my design in the house was snow
drift we have three categories of
judging first yes last one is
explanation sure okay so this is ours we
worked really hard to craft it the theme
is snowdrift ours being me mark we
working together team you can tell by
our color being blue yes I know did that
for a playfulness gas just good and
that's Tyler's
you can take this package it's a perfect
toddler I know exactly what I'm I can
see very clearly yes that is exactly how
that went down
yeah hmm [ __ ] it I have a horrible
truth to reveal to you
you're gonna never look at us the same
again yeah we [ __ ] it first win yeah
what are your first glance out of out of
ten editability which is the fourth
category I'm adding into this an ability
we win I think structural integrity is a
clear winner here I'm pretty sure this
one ain't going nowhere survive an
earthquake yeah uh-huh
and it's stronger for it what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger that's it
that's the slogan so alright alright
yeah well we know this explanation so
were it well we're gonna say it one word
at a time yeah so mark and I went to the
extreme lengths to ensure that this
house was made better than his yes
so we looked at the best method to build
a gingerbread house with love because
our love is stronger than his foundation
all right yeah your explanation do it
one word at a time
mine was I was rushed because there was
a snowdrift in a giant earthquake that
happened yeah which destroyed the
structural integrity and then there were
monsters from the trash heap that came
over and wrecked it well that doesn't
explain how it's good yeah there's an
excuse yeah excuses don't pass here it
is a piece of abstract art mm I mean
ours was art from the beginning
yours is art now oh yeah yeah that for
me for you all right final call final
call uncle will rebuild that boat final
call so this one is the decision our
love is stronger than Tyler's house it's
the final word from the judges now on to
stage three
[Music]
alright so that was Santa's coming to
town the third day of the 12 days of
Christmas hope you enjoyed that one I'm
feeling a little bit better and
hopefully by tomorrow I'll be 100%
better so thank you everybody so much
for watching again ah my ear and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]